to the finest a staircase please hold
back
please hold both hangouts in case the
same or weightloss degrees if anyone is
unable to user stage would they please
allow others to exit the room before
they go to the fire escape door when
they can then be given assistance our
assembly point would be in the public
car problem the side of a civic suite
please do not delay about creations
respectively belongings please do not
return to the building and still give me
permission to do so by the council staff
please don't this please this meeting is
audio recorded thank you very much
secondly just in case somebody else
turns up your father
no that's my walk sorry you thought you
tap it that's where they came is it's
off for seven thank you all for coming
out this evening the first items are
Polly for absence I have councillor and
yet Mason substitute is counselor mr.
Hall thank you just like to come in say
me
colleges first counselor mr. Becker's
counselor mrs. constable counselor Peace
Corp counsel mr. Dale Walker so it's an
independent person who can say mr.
Stanley and I any other apologies at all
okay number two substitute members we've
always said that's Considine higher
substitute this evening non-members
obtained in our counts are Julie good in
and counselor mr. hora again
you very much for coming I'm in it to
the last meeting in Hilden twin check
the September it's everybody read them
into a nice diamond am I so moving
nothing trim yes thank you very much
members number five to receive
declarations of interest there are none
number six member learning and
development just a brief introduction to
chairman the the review committees as
the standards committee to consider
adjustments to member training
arrangements that provide for increased
member input into program content
together with consideration of
amendments to the process of mandatory
training so the observations that the
review committee is set out at a DTD of
report on tonight's agenda
and that includes an element of officer
commentary but really chairman it's it's
it's only in the committee thank you
okay anybody like to start
okay come on counselor Mason can't you
suggest that we take it one bit at a
time because I think otherwise we're
going to go round in circles then so if
that's appropriate madam chairman if I
can address the first observation by the
officers that the Sanders committee
would convene a working group to impose
not etc I think this in general a very
positive idea and it would allow that
both remembering fault
it would allow for greater involvement
of all people certainly having the full
feedback forms which I haven't since
there's something on this committee and
I mean I know they produce but where
they swirl about I don't know would be a
good idea that the only observation you
have is that we're saying the chairman
and vice-chairman of standards which I
have you think would be appropriate but
it also says all group leaders I think
it should be group leaders or their
nominees because group leaders by
definition and the most busy of people
and we would be putting a greater degree
of work on them and if we equally say
that the working group would be
preferred to say in Norfolk the group
leader and or or their nominee from
their group which would still keep it
cross party the other reason for that is
I think we're all aware that on each
party we have people with specialist
experience we certainly have to people
that work in education and their
expertise would be useful I know that so
with the subject group of at least one
person in that field and that would
allow the working group to tap into that
expertise and also expertise and
long-serving members who perhaps can
give a greater insight onto the type of
training that they've found been
and that would go for would help me
remembers the suggestion there I think
broadly speaking is a positive one but
I'm open to anyone else it's commenting
counselor did you want to comment on
we're going to keep with number a first
if that's okay
yes I'll just go back to that yeah I
think that's always gonna call me to
anyone yes sorry I'm a busy guy right
I'm just double-checking that what's the
one yes sorry that was the one because
that's one reason I suggest coming from
em I think I was gonna say I'm saying
essentially the same appointment Oh
Oscar suggests it's slightly different
in that he perhaps a group nominee
robbing the the leader of the groups to
think perhaps leaders have a different
perspective sometimes to two members on
this and this is main cast mr. Faison
centers I would bound to the expertise
of there's at least two members in a
group who who are in education one of
them is actually does courses for for
businesses rather than for younger
people so he's much more personal he's
his experiences would be very good for
this for instance and I'll say that was
the only suggestion I'm having to take
on board Christmases which mrs. Mason
seen with the nominees of group babies
and said that's fine that's all on that
win thank you just come back on that and
say that slightly
father subject the last training session
we had which was only on Tuesday was one
that was put forward by members and that
as far as I'm aware it's the best attend
week we've had for a long time so it
does show that where I mean okay it was
very important subject as well but
having said that does show that when
members have an import the attendance is
greater and what we do want is to
high attendance and I think that's a
good comment though counselors so what
would you so what would your suggestion
be you're saying
group leaders or a nominated person
groom their nominating a brick nominate
yeah can I have any other comment yes
sir thank you madam chairman I've no
problems with item I on accept what has
already been discussed but how does that
square with the fact that the standards
committees responsibility is to set the
training agenda chairman if cleanup took
two observations firstly in terms of the
the group leader I think that in a sense
the reference to group videos about the
waiting they're groovy they can bring
you know you may have nominees others
involved but I think members have
recognized that it's sometimes useful to
have the sort of group leaders in in our
involvement in some way in terms of
those committees responsibilities in
terms of its terms of reference it's got
sort of they've got at eight or nine
responsibilities one of those is to
determine member training program
there's nothing to stop the committee
taking this approach on the basis of the
suggested approach on the basis that it
brings flexibility and other sort of
benefits that members are suggesting in
general could could be useful it would
still be a working group of the
committee and if it got any issues we'll
report back and part of the that the
possible you know so suggesting here is
that if if the working group felt it it
would be valuable to go beyond the
general parameters set by this committee
then it would recommend a change back in
to to this committee is that sort of I
think the idea is can we have a working
group so it's a working good to sort of
discuss what type what meetings a lot
training courses should should come up
for a year but you'll still have it just
still have a Standards Committee anyway
and it have to be brought to the
standard scan which I would assume if we
discuss in training for the year for the
for the Chancellor's German the actual
bone comment here wouldn't mean that it
had to report back into this committee
it would give the of the the the the
working group authority to be sort of
fleet of thirds and and respond to
member thoughts and perhaps
recommendations at a point in the year
when if there is a decision to have
certain size of training trainers and
what-have-you could be approached and if
there were any issues you know the work
that could be reconvened that that's
that's what this would mean if you were
to have that Plus this committee meeting
and going through it again you'd really
be doubling or repeating the the work
and certainly from an officer resource
perspective but I mean this is just one
but mean you know that that's that was
the intent behind the suggestion so that
is just a suggestion
yes boy sorry thank you know eventually
mr. Bob Ross doctors cleared up the
quickly I had because I didn't quite
understand if you did or didn't from the
last pick that up Thank You counsel try
you have to realize I am taken today if
any any other questions on a members
with the working party honors was
understood working for you and Ted had
to come back and report to a committee
otherwise you Mars would you say other
committees they're gonna make decisions
in common law their working party
correct a working group can have an
element of a tease you could form a
subcommittee with even more teeth and
and all recommending recommending in if
you were to form a subcommittee then it
would have to be formally convened with
the genders you know and and and all
this sort of administration around that
it couldn't be perhaps as nimble but you
know that's possible as well the other
thing that I know review committee was
was mindful of a sort of thing that the
officers are is that Roger it's quite
rare in having a committee with
responsibility for member training that
has full reporting in in this way which
takes resource in its own you know in
its own and and and and from the officer
point of view
if members feel it's not working then
it's not working and so but it is you
know you could have a subcommittee you
could you could recommend keeping it as
it as it as it is the only other officer
is sort of in the aging but colleagues
in you know over the last year it often
seems to be that's you know a group of
members perhaps group leaders are are
sort of involved and I need not going to
a committee but but that you know that
there are issues there for members and
she's trying to get there
that makes write which is sort of
recognized because we're sort of
operating to ignore we have that member
challenge selected developments and that
had its own requirements in a sense
they're not around anymore so it's about
getting you know just 100 point as far
as I understand a moment trying this out
by the portfolio holder and the officers
is that correct
sorry trying into the moment the topics
of the training yourself other people
failure will turn and the officers they
get together disposable trainee might be
useful it's how you ever take away from
that more as I mean in advance of a
municipal year officers consult officer
colleagues and and s for thoughts about
what what may be in a program there's
also feedback from members through forms
that have been developed and and you
know the reason mechanisms mechanisms
that are maybe you know could could be
observations about about how effective
they are and that's brought together and
reported into the standards committee at
its last meeting of a municipal year in
preparation for the next one
but it doesn't give the flexibility that
you might associate with what trainings
about if it helps yes what point with
this new system does the standards
committee become responsible for the
training if it's being done separately
from the committee who had no sight
other than when it goes wrong at what
point that I picked up the pieces
because it's alright having loads of
folks making their mind up and maybe
something going on personal training
sites which we've had in the past and
these committees had to stop it half a
dozen other people and only will it be
reported back as if this committee is
responsible for that training I mean at
this stage it's gone yeah I think I can
clarify that the reason this has been
referred to as for review is because the
standard committee hasn't been
overseeing the training yes and Emily
lives it would look like that would
continue
no at the moment what we're getting is
we're getting a report will you see that
report but there's no mechanism for
anything to be done when we have a
training session we all fill in an
assessment form I would have expected
those forms to come back to this
committee of this committee to assist
them but Sir my knowledge has never
happened the question should be why
well I think what we're trying to do is
to put in a system in time for the next
municipal year so look at the moment the
attendance at the training is very low
the training takes up officer time both
in running the caucuses and
administering them if we have officers
and sometimes as law officers sitting
there and we have two members it is not
viable and there is something wrong so
this is a scheme that the officer has
put forward to resolve that and
personally I think it's a positive
moment because certain is the regret or
involvement here I mean you couldn't
change the makeup of the working group I
mean this committee has it is gifted to
do that personally I don't think the
group leaders should be group nominees
because the group leaders by definition
decide on the nominee so but it gives
flexibility whereas if you say group
leaders you're committing the group
leader which I don't think we have a
right to do as a committee so I do think
I will disagree with mr. basta with that
it should be a group nominee but this
committee might decide that it shouldn't
be just group nominees it should be
nominees from the standards committee a
working party from the sun is commin
Turing that I don't think the element of
concern here is the composition
particularly of the working group I
think it's very important that we have
that I think it's very important this
change is implemented but if members on
this committee look it's saying that now
he shouldn't be Roopa nominees it should
be or perhaps we should have an
independent person there as well I mean
I'm quite open to that suggestion but
this committee does need to recognize
that it hasn't been fulfilling that role
completely and if we
by this mechanism that's been suggested
by the officers would at least put
committee of aldermen in there and
memory involvement which is what the
objective works I think that is fair
about that just listening from the
outside it seemed to move that you want
the leader of certain groups pixel
weather is going to go and at no point
until people see the objects on the
decision is that standing that's a
definition of working free from the Sun
is committee will report back to the
Senate absolutely thank you previous
speakers I would that's what you're
proposing Christine I would certainly
given them the responsibility for
training six for this committee yes I
was going to say was that the the
working group as I read in a does have
within it the Chairman and the vice
chairman of this committee anyway so two
of the members would be from this
committee I I
I think the review committee was trying
to say group leaders all their nominees
I haven't said companies but I think I
make you better so you've got you've got
a widespread view from various groups as
well
so I don't see that the from how he is
suggested here the standard squeegee
doesn't Ellison's say that the working
very precise it would be chaired by the
chairman of the standard switch anyway
is that that's how it normally work so
you have a great say what goes on in
that respect perhaps some suggest a
compromise if we recommend that this
probably is as a head cook with a group
of nominees doesn't mean that they've
got to pick the nominees one bit from a
standards committee logically the group
would do that but they're also on that
working group that we approved an
independent person but I think having
that father perspective would be helped
that was my reason for suggesting we
didn't form it from this committee and
who wouldn't who would actually within
the group make those nominee well it's
the same with sorry through the chair
it's the same as with any committee the
the gift of an appointment to a working
group or a committee is in the gift of
the group leader of that group which is
why it's group nominees so in the case
of the Conservative Party it counts the
couple decide who he felt was best
suited in the case of you keep counsel
the hook way and they could either go
themselves or nominate someone my
expectation would be that generally
speaking they would they would choose
someone that's on this committee it's
logical and but I don't think we should
predetermine what
but the to that degree I think we should
leave that as as he's done at full
council as it's always done by the group
yes it could be a possibility that the
training program could be publicized
further advanced and made widely
available and that every single counts
with it have some input if there was
something that people felt that they
didn't really be training on or that
those subject matters have been
completely ignored in in the past
perhaps that could be some direct input
from from everyone but I do believe that
so I we do these assessments every years
and get an idea to get an idea of what
trainings members want anyway
well I think we're getting away from
them from a at the moment I think we've
got it with your side I understand what
counselor means this lungs sound good
idea and I'm looking really committee
now we've got a few wide range of
counselors on our committee as it is
from different parties the only the only
ones we probably haven't got is you kit
okay so we have got a wide range of
person so we could as a counselor me
said pick out the working group from
there from here really rather than
having to go outside and asking the
group leaders to nominate somebody else
I mean if if like everything else if
some is really interesting then they can
turn up as as non-members anyway and
they can put in there there's their
thoughts yes I can mr. post-op territory
phone remember can turn up to a working
group or working
I can of the no income no puppy-sized
well there are formal meeting the value
of a working group is is they don't have
to be vetted where where it stops sort
of being sort of making decisions and
that aren't that aren't decisions in
relation to council policy and you know
Kiki type of decisions now this
committee could if it wished recommend
that there's nothing to stop I thought
my working group inviting you know for
that members along but I think you'd
normally expect the decisions to be made
by those that are nominated for the
working group I think the idea is its
small ineffective yeah that's the try
think about Jeremiah Siskin to mention
the important that cancer mister high
raised about whether other members like
members could come into the working
group and indeed other members would it
be open to members of the public issue
not working group my depression attack
sauce we were talking about this working
about how many people we are we asking
for just position to say here and does
it well that would be six would know if
you've got four groups and she's got
with chairman Bastion thank you to
chairman vice chairman Zhou was saying
so say no yeah including yeah generally
and the independent person so it would
be selling which is quite a large
working
we can always go on on our stance
committee anyway yeah if you just made
out of councils and you try to recommend
more trainings ahead for you would you
not leave my experts so an officer from
computer on back planning training the
plane planning officer so I should say
yes we can do that training board
it falls under somewhere else see it's a
it's doing its excuse me job but
that'sthat's goes on to say because
planning training not just for instance
in in my view if if the working group
was to meet at the appropriate time in
the year and had the right sort of
information and concluded that planning
or an attorney has to be appropriate
then then it would be a place to
determine you when the big when when the
big time for the officers you know
Michela myself to to actually explore
you know getting getting training
exactly to that to that requirement
it may be at times that some officers
are very very keen to say members could
really be do with training on that but
again that could be brought into the
working group any did the obvious it
could come along to the working group
and explain why yeah Eve yeah but it's
basically helped see you moving from one
everyone meeting yields points a tone
because it seems like we can serve the
working group is gonna recommend
training the office is gonna take it
away and say yes we can do that what
maybe Bobby's like better than coming
back again we have sixteen
okay or you just we make small one the
ideal would indeed be for for the
working group to convene and have all
the information it needs and and have a
sort of one hit on on everything I
imagine I mean that's an ideal that
something to aim for I like that when
you attempt something like this for the
first time you know there's got to be
teething stuff and stuff but I mean it
might take one or two municipal years
well everyone but you get there you know
and I think we're the officers I mean I
mean there is you know Michelle
obviously as part of her role involved
with member training Karen personally
helps administer that a little bit
clearly when we've thinking about this
we're thinking well we can't sort of
double up or or duplicate but that's the
sort of thing that's being discussed you
know is necessarily going to involve
more work if it's the right work if you
you know and we'd have to save it was a
proper way you know it's we still have
to decide how we're going to work this
now it seems have change yes counselor
gosh thank you Jim just listening to the
saying
where was the starting point going to be
then for this first working group or
just generally working group when it
means because if it's just a let's pull
out the air anything we think might be a
good training idea look at no work and
when you start to put meetings
well it's suggesting here January and
February which would presumably for this
first sequence right if we're talking
then about through your chairman
training this made for example I suspect
we wouldn't even get to a decision
before April so what's the format
intended what's behind the suggestion of
the working group and how about first
meeting work well I think the the driver
for this is the the hope of the review
committee that revised arrangements that
a more member member sort of focus could
be in place for the next municipal year
which isn't far away know through you to
ask the question would that be the
intention and of offices which other to
actually survey members all members
initially asking what they made like or
me think they need for training for this
year and do that fairly soon so there
was some information for them to work
with Sherwood's think counselor going I
think the review routine my mother is
that she thought I was unable to attend
that meeting I think the idea around
group leaders or their nominees the
change I think the group is ever I think
nobody's worked just as well it was
because they group leaders would have
knowledge of what their members were
expecting nothing that was probably
intention behind that so
have necessitated surveys first the
group leaders söderling members as to
what they make I think what would be the
most what trading I think I need some
that sorry that's what I'm a father
yeah I was going to dribble detail than
that yours may be through you Jimmy
yours may be very up to speed with
what's needed but maybe some of this may
not be quite some to speak presumably
this would also like their member input
before they actually determines what
they thought their group needed so there
has to be upfront some kind of survey
that says you know what do you think you
might need before someone actually makes
that decision this is what you're going
to get so timeline is mine I took too
much I can't sleep pretty awesome
feedback from the pink falls you know
that could be fed back that would be
initially giving you some information
sorry they don't have the pig films it
says black any eye that they would have
the performance to do it from the
transpose of ascorbic acid she's not me
coming in from that that's the feedback
from the forum topics my understanding
is that that's not a very good return
always
whatever color they are get completed or
completed appropriately I think what
really but it got to you side how do you
want to set this up is the first thing
and then we're going to worry about how
we're going to drive it from there
yes I've either got to decide are we
going to do these these people on this
committee in this working group is it
going to be from this Standards
Committee are we looking at outside
people other people on the earth or now
Council mr. Evans I would but firstly I
was thinking if we could have people
that were already on the on the young
dannis committee but I'm you know I'm at
four so can I should be first consult
neither can we so I suggest I put a
proposal in for the members being from
the standards committee so I've been
chairman vice chairman and forth and an
independent person person so there'll be
seven of us from the stands committee
that's what I propose as a working party
yes counselor can I just come in there
if you're going to do that it's going to
be a very large working group and if
you're employing your members from the
Sanders case which I have no objection
with at all then I don't see the need
for the vice chair as well if you'll
respect me
I think you keep it just where the bomb
is smaller and more effective it should
be the Chairman an independent person
and perhaps three other members I think
if we're getting it too big you're not
getting a working group you're getting
another committee which is nothing
attention but that would be if you'd
like to take that on board and if
everyone's agreeable then I'm service
supports you're talking of five yeah
five members from
Standards Committee including the by
including a chairman and an independent
from an independent person man without
hope are we yes go on campus look into
the future and the UK because stuff free
parties at the moment would it maybe be
a member from each party there's not
because as it comes in more parts coming
to be more we don't worry about it
Terri's one like members can we agree
this then we're talking about five five
members from this work from this group
the chairman of Stannis chemically
dependent and its three other members
now these three other members are they
from the other parts are they from I
think if ideally we'll spread it I don't
think you need to tie ourselves down I
think it should ideally big from across
party because right and if we say cross
party then that ladies it to flexibility
in the future technically it should be
prosperous I think you're [ __ ] crazy
sorry sorry nice night directed any
other comments at all yes can't thank
chairman and there's no reason why the
vice chairman of this committee can't be
in the working group you just wouldn't
be vice-chairman of the working group
yes
have we got an agreement yeah
have you got agreements heaven is that
how what to go forward all these members
everybody else we agree to that
that's for the members Jim I think I
think you know the karoli of Bobby it
would be that the you know if the
recommendation is that this that group
it's palpable you know with the
recommendation be that it gets together
in January and February with a view to
influencing the member training program
for the next municipal year on the
understanding that actually is because
the short timeline this time in future
years the the point when that working
group was knees would be at a point that
would get all the information fed in
that this committee currently does and
and it can work that through any
thickness generally if you like support
I plan for proposal if I happen to
second it so that we can then move on to
the detail of how we go to obtain the
information right now we do it was
proposing leadership sorry I'm figuring
you III yeah we just got aggressed again
that the status committee could convene
a working group composed of the chairman
of the committee three other members I
was cross screwed across screen and an
independent person for the purpose of
agreeing the content of the training
program for the following areas
so that since I'd yes a second thank you
I'll be willing over there three thank
you very much Thank You members so I can
be going to be pleased members and yeah
think babies all day today I think madam
chair time I think it's covered but I've
been asked to make some comments for one
of our brief members who is an
educationist and the observation that
they have made is that we should be
considering different training for newer
members and refresher makers which I'm
sure we can look at in general February
the working group can look at but also
from of their experience that sessions
of over one hour tend to be more
productive now I'm not going to comment
because if I'm not an expert in this but
but it was something that they said that
really the message should be short sharp
and effective in them after that time
the observation was that people will
listen but they won't absorb the
information so perhaps that's something
that we can consider that's it'd be nice
if the community could result just like
committee meetings but this it was a
point made and I think it was about an
episode for someone else to bring that
up so I have time to say so what you're
saying counselor may see you can feel
the training courses go on to knowledge
that what you're saying on I'm not
personally I think it depends on the
methods of delivery and it depends on
the subject I don't think there should
be an obligation the moment there seems
to be an assumption that a training
session will last for 132 say for
there's no reason if the training if
it's a wreath after or something that
we've all done before like the code of
conduct that should be but very sick
simple weave right revision it shouldn't
be a whole new there but he said the new
members obviously and on the call so I'm
not saying they go on too long
I don't think they should be prescribed
got time for that
because the subject matter should lend
itself naturally to the time that's
effective to communicate that point
rather than the impression of the moment
I think we get is that there is a
certain time frame and it will take that
time frame and I can remember a certain
going back a bit now certain courses
because someone commented that if you
didn't stay for that two hours you
wouldn't get you wouldn't get your mark
or your amount of your training so that
there has been that perception that
there is a certain time that you've got
to sit there for I don't think that's
the proper way of approaching training
that was the only thing that I think we
should involve added with training on
Tuesday which was basically split into
two parts
where we had a now we should go to
presentation and now really the next
there was questions and answers which I
thought was brilliant because we covered
a lot and we moved around a lot Olivia's
talking about Star Trek I learned a lot
more of these questions and answers and
I think for the presentation even though
the presentation is very good for
presentations are always dry because of
loss me personally I mean counts of a
few years I don't understand a lot
beyond panic and don't understand a lot
of what they say and I understand more
from the questions and answers again I
think it's one of the things that the
working group will bring up anyway so I
understand Chancellor Hawaii it's very
just to emphasize the point I think it
was more that two and a half hours solid
of training he's not ruined and quite
frequently I've been in a session where
the person presented Gator said to
autumn
we are planning a break at such-and-such
a time and then people will say no we're
going straight on through to get it out
of the way and I think that that's the
problem of inspect people and
our three and a half is maximum rain I
think that's one of the things you can
look at any weapon yes yeah chairman
overwork that being part of the
recommendation in that if you have to
trace back minutes over the years that
that two two and a half hours afternoon
in what we know it sort of came from
this committee of more points on it it
were useful you know that's how the
committee feels for that to be part of
us so we get a recommendation on that
I'll be John I'm just going recommend a
recommendation because that moves it's a
shift away from you know this can I say
one thing that was already mentioned one
thing that I think it's important when
tickly in respect to new members is some
sort of induction training and there was
two recommendations for the review
committee and a third well Toma I think
would be good for new members some sort
of induction course is what the council
does and member decision-making
structure and processes I think is
important that is therefore again I
think this isn't going to go into the
working group this is dry so that's the
idea of it in words but going through
this I can't support it do you want
remaining sessions we used to have
mm-hmm counsel do shifted away from what
we used to have six seven years ago
we were more than induction
yeah well I was going to say is the it's
all very well saying we only need an
hour but on some of the training
sessions it's necessary to have longer
because you actually do it practical so
for example licensing where you go down
and do a practical if that's part of it
then if it takes more than an hour it
takes more than an hour and then if you
um as you have a comfort break in
between you go into a fresh fruit fresh
and you're ready to like when you're
through at school you don't think we're
saying that pamphlet but nothing we're
saying with it we're saying the night
and I know myself after two hours of an
evening I'm falling asleep yeah so I
think it's down to the the trainer and I
think a nice is one of the things that
the committee will will obviously look
at in this car so yes she's going to say
that the compulsory training forms part
of tonight's agenda
yeah so they will need to be a view on
that as well as sort of phasing to see
if you wanted sorry yes come in here but
I tend to be a parish training for the
him plenty comfortable we expect you
back and I think that came out of it and
all the parish councillors attendee
degrade it it was just too condensed
there was for the presenters and there
wasn't and it went on so longer we had
to the lately museum Friday I said
that's a labor mated better finish and
people were still wanting to ask
questions so I think there was just too
much acting to the mating here
mr. Mason I think to clarify the quote
we're not prescribing that the training
session should be one and two hours or
any length of time what we're suggesting
is that we should leave liquid seven
depending on the subject matter and its
relevance to new and existing counselors
take a view on the time with them that
the training session should be geared to
the needs of that subject not to
prescribe time so it's the other way
around instead of filling in the time
what is needed
[Music]
referring to breaks myself rather than
where we're doing took half hour
straight out without Franklin for the
last hour yeah I think at the time him
being the development of the training
course itself okay some things were you
know so word is that the length of the
training session should be determined by
the lead and nature of the training
session and not to a prescribed time and
that the committee and the working group
should consider that and also the
various needs of new newer or more
experienced counselors because sometimes
the need would be different when there's
a counselor and we have said that
like maybe that you want to sessions or
one it maybe you want an hour for
another and the prescription of a set
time I don't think is helpful we've got
a proposal on the table coming up a
second new at all to me
yes can't do secondly I just want either
face out on its previous them cats to
make them but all I'm saying is that if
it does go on longer than an hour then I
still think after now like these to have
that break because just after now you do
start yeah all I'm saying is I think I
think something like that depends on the
people that are in the room if you get
people the room si no seven out of seven
out of nine say no and then when I carry
on and I have too many become a
breakfast the dancer the toilet we just
depends but again that's something that
the you know the committee can have a
look at the other ones we're going on I
have a very fine but what I want to say
Kevin is did you know they're working
group to give guidance to trainers
whether they offices or external about
you know the expectations around breaks
and you know and and and and also its
expectation around length and you know
and what have you and that's something
the working group against you know if it
is teeth into okay so you would agree on
that members yes agree Thank you Thank
You members here we go on to another
former before going to say you we
touched on it earlier we wanted to get
information do we want to do that before
we go on to the mandatory training
incarnations they come back to me
preferred those council only suggested
and it complete quite right in that we
need to get information before they work
for it leads
we had survey information just a survey
of members asking them to feed into the
officers by a certain date so the first
of January is as simple as that any
training requirements any observations
they want to make that we've got all
that any information can we not add that
on can we not add that as a
recommendation - I thought so can we not
make that recommendation at the end of
this after D then we can find a way of
what wending names the minute but I
think it's about a fresh survey into the
january/february work with making pull
us what we've already got education from
yes memory into what they think they
might yeah fresh sort of casting of it
for the next working group and what
we've already what officers will be got
yeah I think will be a bit clunky this
year and it obviously timing but but
that that that is a principle this
actually is interesting so I suggest
that we also ask officers if they think
there's something because it sometimes
they'll be changed in the law right yeah
it may be business think of something is
appropriate so though we try to get more
men room or I'm not trying to escape you
although so alone so you recommend your
recommendation are you count
and you know Sigonella Casa basic settle
right every any comments on a first the
mandatory training at all
I don't know starting this time and I
don't through trouble with the mandatory
trial somewhere why page has done which
is like a philosophy is on the for safe
trading little bit trouble with it and I
think it needs to be looked I don't know
if that to be the case for the working
group to do what this committee to do
but I think there are for planning
training for instance I think there's
there's a there's a difference between
if you're an experienced counselor who
who knows paying quite well to sit
through a course that a new member I
have to sit through seems a bit
pointless was one point the other point
is on nice and singer I took the point
of Casa just couldn't set about the
nicest suit rate but license he said you
have the licensing committee which may
make policy changes which I think and
then you have the licensing
subcommittees which need that the very
detailed training about how you deal
with a subcommittee hearing so I think
there's two different sorts of training
under and at the moment I don't I think
the train but I don't believe you need
the training in the same way to sell on
or substitute for the committee itself
as you would do for the subcommittee
because if you talk about policy we talk
about policy all the time as as
counselors and I think that that would
be should be an issue typically to
preclude you from sitting on the
committee itself we might preclude you
from sitting on the subcommittee I think
that should be looked at as well that
was the main point and also with regard
to manage realize
Centralia sometimes there's has been set
before us with planning sometimes there
might be no changes that's going to be
planning for we'd never happened at them
open but licensee septic them will
change would be pretty much the same
quite often they might be an echo
through when sometimes it's just an
update which why we need it which might
be an hour's course as canceling C's
makes the suggested I think that needs
to be taken on board with these courses
thank you so are you saying
counselor that you don't think they
should be managed to meant it to Rio are
you saying that kid I think I think
planning I have no comment that be a
momentary I think licensee training to
sit on the committee itself should not
be mandatory but should be further sub
committees where it is relevant if you
make if we're making policy we need to
understand the law why don't we make
policy in other areas without having a
mandatory committee or mandatory
training mandatory training for that
policy what I'm saying I can understand
it for the subcommittee could be
mandatory but I believe it needs to be
mandatory to see on the interim
committee itself when you're talking
about the policy of something they need
to be I don't think Brady has changed in
icing over the last year it doesn't need
to be in this era new members they are
suppose but then why should existing
members you know quite well might need a
refresher but members who are brand new
might be something very detail much more
detailed
I'll get the point that's all thank you
I would certainly echo what constant
always says I mean I have sat on the
licensing committee without training and
I had no problem in understanding
documentation or as a policy but I
certainly wouldn't be able to sit on
Isis in hearing and I think that that's
got muddled out there used to the
training used to always be just for the
earrings not for the committee and he's
somehow
running into the toe so I think that's
just a sentence that needs to be
clarified I mean I'm sure mr. kosko
correct me they never used to be the
case today so it means you're gone I
just wanted to say that when we sort out
subcommittee members they're taken from
the pool of the licensing committee so
to have people not trained you'd have
fewer people to pick from yeah yes I
appreciate that issue yeah with the the
training going on from what councilor
homer saying and it was you'll end up if
you do narrow it down to only having a
very small number of people attending
training you'll only have that the two
or three that are on the subcommittee if
you end up there in committees China the
intention isn't is only trying to all
throw the intention is for the whole
world of the licensing committee if
possible to attend the training but some
members can't they've got work
commitment silent commitments if they
can't they shouldn't be pretty clearly
from attending the licensing committee
making policy and also you're stopping
people subbing by doing that so so
you're you're actually eliminating
limiting your your committee involvement
and you're restricting it which I don't
think was the intention I'm not
suggesting that only three people get
trained because they usually my
understanding is when there's a
licensing hearing that the officers will
fire and and find out who is available
for their hearing of the members are
trained and the
I deal with way that all members are
trained but if for some reason a member
isn't trained I obviously can't attend
to hearing but they should not be
excluded from making policy decisions so
that was a suggestion or night that I
expanded my he lists are configured
counselor boy I was just going to try
say the same thing I think it's not to
say that no one needs trading but it it
precludes people from substituting for
instance on them but licensing committee
meets very rarely I think I might have
had maybe one or two a year but the most
I would suggest on the licensing
committee itself over the policy and it
seems to be unfair its you're not able
to substitute onto that committee if
you've read all the documents as you
would for any other committee and you'll
be precluded from having a substitute
substitute for you because they haven't
done the training it precludes
substitutes from that from that
committee in my mind you may just take
me to toe and you can come in I just
wanted you to say about licensing always
which I would licensing you could you
can have them it's only worked for
people that don't actually work
full-time because the training is at
half one you're saying that you sign you
on one that again so the Commission can
clip the committee can look at
counseling mr. Sawyer so I wouldn't
worry too much on that square with the
trainer whether you go downstairs you do
a lot of property leaving and I'm
thinking like planning training maybe
feeling like the newer members if they
had their like run-through of how we got
wings like when we went when we when we
ever licensing training we go downstairs
and we act out a proper hearing so like
for new members especially ones that
aren't on the treaty may be you know
that you should have like a plane roll
downstairs so that new members load you
know planning how it would get nothing
that's gonna good that's gonna get
involved in with with the committee
itself I think at the moment we trying
to work out what we're doing the
mandatory training
let's do with planning for
for one or the other I think yeah yeah I
mean I mean it's just a couple of
comments in check firstly mandatory
training is currently in the gift of
this committee and stays in the gift of
this committee unless you decide to us
somewhere else like a working group to
look at it
secondly in terms of office of resource
in intenseness and members and members
worry it worries it can get very
divisive and is the most difficult
aspect of what you'll be looking at and
thirdly Rochford in a way it's good the
duties but are mandatory arrangements
going across three committees the way
they do with the intensity they do is is
quite rare and you know we we in a way
we're ahead of other council but in
other ways it's very very than a lot of
requirements there that go beyond what
most other councils and members you
wouldn't necessarily come across and
it's true that with licensing that the
as a matter of practice it hasn't met
that often and there's a distinction
between policy and you know some of
hearings and for offices it's about
having a group of members that they can
go to to get to a hearing that have been
trained you know I did we most of the
licensing members but you know so
generous councillor yes amazing sorry I
seem to be speaking a lot tonight I
think that we have taken all quite a lot
from the local group of change and for
that reason I would like to see a little
change to the mandatory we talked about
planning for the moment of the mandatory
planning training the the only thing I
think that should be looked at is a
consideration of different training for
new members and existing members perhaps
at the beginning of the year
think something that was done last time
I think perhaps the working group could
just consider that but I do think the
working groups you consider the topic
matter because we've all sat through
mandatory clinic training that has
trained us or something that we have
known maybe even put on at all no
ability to influence and that is not the
good use of training resources and
second no good use of your model
resources so I wouldn't I would like to
make sure that the planning manager
planning training is as the last session
was is appropriate on things that the
planning committee can actually
influence such as conditions so your
room sizes not on things that are
outside even our officers have no
knowledge of it's not helpful but are we
still sticking to the mandatory planning
training though I think as he's at the
moment yes it's just a subject matter I
think another going through this so on
the license students sorry
Sam say something you need to be clear
that you want the working group to look
at that part of manager training because
that is distinct from you know what it
would be better look at so just the
sunny yeah yeah but not otherwise
I think with the amount of alteration as
we're doing I think that should be left
generate just the subject matter and
that and the question of whether they
should be a different induction course
if you're not familiar maybe this is
something this committee can come back
to but but I mean there's a lot now
going on in terms of the next municipal
you terms of members and lead singer yes
I think with the licensing one which is
always one that can go wrong is the
officers must have a group of people
or a fight with what they're doing from
me so that would be the first to say
whoever all of them they like cigars for
every training session committee can
decide on anyone who needs to sit on a
hearing ask the before we try it because
if that goes wrong the council goes
skin.what cynically the enzyme is such a
big power so I think you can adjust that
the most yourselves but don't lose the
fact that if you're not up to sitting on
that hearing and really the officers
should be so poor I'm not too sure about
that so if you lose that you're going to
end up in big trouble so that can be
done by decree meeting and the same
applies not so cleverly
with the planning if you choose not to
listen to the officer that some members
had in the past the backlash in there is
a redness it's not only do you get
publicity you can also get fired and
then you have to read it all again how
do we get paint on your face because you
didn't want it pink so that's the reason
that you complained about the building
so the trainings got something that at
least all of the people can have a sigh
or get up and say something have a broad
idea as for new members I have no idea
so you can treat them as they used to
separately they all had induction the
first induction funnily enough was the
standards that
she must answer that's quite sweet it's
about four sentences and if they've all
got that and they're all those questions
on it you can then go on to the other do
you even want a chair a meeting of
course I think that's what I signed on
for
well you need to be trained because
there's nothing worse than attending a
meeting where first of all the public
and unwind with it and then why not some
members of another group decide to give
the person [ __ ] and they don't know how
to control it so that's another one that
you should look at it's easy to think
you can share it because if you get some
real clever people it's the hardest
thing in the world to do and I'm
surprised how few people have actually
been trying to cheer meetings I don't
want to go that's the Mike thing so the
present time the mentoring planning
training is as is but we're going to go
to the work and go to the content okay
yeah and an induction okay and the and
the license in one yes cancer maybe just
have one look at another timing as well
as the afternoon people gonna work oh
that's something else book yeah
yeah and they're licensed yes counselor
it's quite important that for instance
substitutes could be an add on the
actual committee itself without the
training though this is nothing has been
Freddie clear from everyone ever spoken
so far that there is a the with the
squeegee should recognize the difference
between on that committee or sitting on
a review hearing the better training
comes in observing the clinic and our
substitute lucky at the moment this
committee could acknowledge that tonight
it's given all these out without asking
you know that that can be the case from
here on in with that busy yeah that's
for licensing yeah I think we should
also do something like a first date oh
you can't thirsty that's great thank you
madam chairman coming back to the life
system hearing as we were warrior
they are very very important there are
modern Isis committee I've had the
licensing hearing training there was
some months ago but the handle ha I
wouldn't be confident in actually
chairing licensing hearing and I feel
there should be some sort of extra
training to halfway through the year
because the first train I hit was some
months ago
Oh again I'll sing that song can be done
on agree there I feel we are get a lot
once a year but I feel comfortable
chairing a lysosome hearing yeah I think
that's that's what we're talking about
them as license in citizen and are
licensed in can like you say license in
peer in a female did I use it right on
by foodie news just an hour's catch um
do you not mean perhaps you could feed
that into the good-looking group is that
my planning person I think that's a good
idea if you feel like that yeah I think
you certainly the good
when the mandatory appeals committee
where we never chair the resolution on
the licensing that we make a distinction
before from the committee to the actual
hearings but there's a distinction of
tracking because also a second need to
cast a higher caliber I can't move it no
okay I'll move it and testimony of a
second big apologies and Jim Sherman I
think again it's worth this committee
recognizing the the point has been made
about maybe by Aniel and his work and by
annual training that allows chairmanship
of Licensing hearings you have medical
comforts without that should come from
this disk imaging and and if members are
happy you know the working group could
could nail that down loads of it any
sorry sorry I'm talking about a member
of the committee I've served on nice it
seemed pretty quite a number of years
I'm not this year I know I think he's
not just chairing our things actually
could you cook over six months seven
months eight months and I actually from
the training and before you actually sit
on a committee even or something review
committee even sell figures just a
refresher they even don't think it is
exorbitant which would include Chairman
chairing it but I think it's just a
refresher could you because the way it
does work you might not be an available
for eight months and then you you're the
only one who eats thank you but I set
off eight months off you've had your
training I think that's again is getting
to the infantry well I was panicking
about some of things like compulsory
chairmanship training I was taking a
half of it out it's fine i six hearings
it make
four members of the committee to
actually see hearing one or two bearings
be there before all there actually you
could visit other authorities licensing
hearings they're similar so you didn't
mean to show you two other authorities
okay
I'm wrong to the mandatory one I've are
we happy with the men trade but as it
stands talking about bills I'm sorry the
appeal to make the appeals committee err
sorry
yes
[Music]
go into the do not settle Appeals so I
don't know but this seems to me to read
and I'll take other members of Iceland
list the same as licensing that yes you
need training and you need refresher
training to sit on the appeals hearing
but again the committee is should be
policy and I'm not sure but I don't know
because it's not a committee I've served
on whether you made training just to sit
on it only committee I would've thought
it was the same as nice to think man I
mean the Appeals is just one committee
and my mother people have been Appeals
review every other day so it's no this
so to sit on the committee do you need
training was it just to hear the appeals
now you need the training just a sitting
what committees you don't need convenes
to hear the appeals you don't have a
subcommittee village during a period of
people are a committee is the appeals
committee very first words but that's
p.m. but don't you need for is policy
somebody changing three flavors the last
one if we do before we love you well the
principles are say that he shouldn't be
if he's not hearing an appeal that you
I'm just saying in that case then that
the refresher training every two years
okay which training these pills every in
always joke I don't really do it two
years but why did we just change it to
anything
give them up the comments have been
there previously
[Music]
does it mean top up or does it [ __ ]
time I do invite you every year I think
I think the idea we I think the idea of
the refresher is if someone like myself
is being as a member that appeals came
with it for a long time but obviously so
new men that they have to do it all this
first type of years but we can change it
to every annually I'm just thinking
particularly it doesn't often experience
[Music]
period would be possible to have
training in advance of the hearing
itself next week and the training yeah
so it could be trained sector annually
then please we were hoping that members
okay D which I think these numbers that
another what we've just been speaking
about yes counselor horn say I'm sorry
dr. dick take photographs of my phone so
date is the feedback forms as I
understand it perhaps be more involved
in determining the non-mandatory aspect
of training programs I think we've
already discussed angular sexy which i
think is the point of the forms which is
the feedback forms isn't it and yes I
think that's not a problem and online
may be well but I think it needs to be
month the forms are quite old-fashioned
there we're asked mrs. the room
satisfactory which always going to be
one of our rooms as I continue I don't
know but I should be tidy schooled I
think it should be we'll get around the
content of course suitability course
rather than the venue of the pulse
maybe Park on the defensive we could
always say well the air conditioning
didn't work well it's saying if your
other forms rigid yes maybe I think I
mean to get proper feedback we need the
forms to designed to give us this
attention is paid back with a prismatic
German I think I think there's two
things here there's that there's that
points about the content but there's
also the concept of maybe than being
online which is something
you and this committee have been you
know sort of picking out which is which
is why here given time frame I mean I I
suspect from from from the minute review
and and and discussion that the online
assessment could be the way forward but
it might be something for the working
groups to be looking at if it can't
achieve you know you know given the
short time frame you know next municipal
year get it get it right for that
including the content if one man can I
also suggest that their forms have not
given out at the meetings in collected
any meetings because I've seen them
ticked before even the caucuses are
finished and it's it's a danger you know
I don't get my to Canada and it's
sometimes they put on the time cleaning
man give you know wine on them to see
they're going out at the beginnings are
when some counselors take them at the
beginning there's something else film in
at the beginning that okay so if it's
completed before very there's like
benefit and there's also a think of
problem in that you're handing them to
the officer that has done the course I
think there should be another method of
than being collective which we can do
okay but it's not it's not a good idea
to just sit there and saying gosh you're
rubbish and leg hear me out you're
you're not going to get valid feedback
that way I think offices will fully
understand that particular their own
experiences and other training is just
about finding a route that doesn't add
to the you know the supporters
resourcing member services but but gets
round that and maybe that's something
again the working group if this
committees happy look at it might not
solve that in january/february
the focus immediately there is about
next municipal year because of it but
it's something yeah I'm certainly
enjoying next year yeah
those libraries while working a great
company they're going after January
February to little bit indeed and I
think we work in groups in the first
instance that that leads to happen it's
just the mindful that once it's set its
way of working hopefully it can then you
know be getting on without you know once
or twice a year and the first instance
everybody knows ESRD remembers three
then that was just for low german no
yeah it brings out the point about
resulting but that's what you made sir
and three two the budgets extra that's
just a note so and for source
information information yeah so really
chairman in terms of the recommendation
that you'd be looking to recommend
through the review committee on the
fifth of December into Council on the
12th of December for this working group
to inform the next municipal year that
would be you you you telling Frank okay
well what we need to advise so play well
because we need to put it in process
there's no we've got to go to the review
committee on the fifth of December to
let them know what we're looking at
doing but this is the training it is
within the power of this committee so
though we can go we can advise review
committee and they can send it to for
counsel if they wish there's nothing to
stop this committee going ahead and
doing it
we have no I mean I'm sure it was to
Boston correct me if I'm wrong but we
are responsible for Frank
in in indeed chairman it was just that
the the review committee asked the the
meeting that to see you know the
recommendations and felt that it should
go they should go to full council I mean
yeah they'd certainly it's all with
anything without that was the that was
the sensitive your madam chair I would
suggest that with the time frame that we
have but yes certainly send it to review
committee certainly then recommend or
agree and or note it and refer to full
council but I do don't think we should
wait in formulating the working group
and getting the information because
otherwise it'll be too late to get that
information thank you
get up and chairman the officers will be
looking to assume that the you know it
gets it gets resolved because obviously
ourselves the ocean so do we need so
before we do recommendation do we need
to decide now about the working group
then the members of the working group at
all you don't need to do that tonight
you can get can be done over the next
few days in consultation you know we we
know that it's sort of if that can come
forward you know it doesn't have to be
right now you know is we know it's it's
it's members of this committee but the
group you know the leaders or the boots
language to identify you know which
which one is been used up to the
committee
well I'll be on it that one else can i
clarify the first meeting than working
group it happens to be January where
every time yes yes chairman that need to
be two or three dates identified and the
phone around to get the optimum date
making sure that that you're there and
hopefully won't you know all the men I'm
quite happy to represent my word on that
that leaves us without a member for dick
Davis but I don't think we've met
someone that's not here so we could have
a name to be confirmed
chairman you know I've got three so far
but they start in agreement with what
you've just agreed if you don't have a
member from that if don't broke you're
not agreeing you haven't got membership
according to what you've just the
thirteen doesn't complete as you saying
prophesy screw nothing like you that
goes against the spirit of what you've
agreed that solution and of course group
not first party all right will crew
pissed you got group you've got four
groups but this assertive group you've
got the greeting logistic restless you
keep a different problems you're
representing the conservative yeah I'm
quite happy to help said Lee pretty much
district mister this group you can some
hang on him
and so we CalSTRS standing would have to
be prone to sick but if it means if he's
not unable to do it then I was there
another remember my only big problem and
I was a feminist committee yeah or if
you vote counts today I've got cancer
Dre down anyway instead he'll be allowed
to - yeah good instead of Christ we
haven't got a vice-chair have we can
have grown five haven't we been agreed
for and I need obsess five all together
yeah cancer drain has a particular
interest I mean we could alter the
recommendation let's see any relevance
to you although I nominated person cuz
we were gonna have some theis chairman
the Chairman wasn't we but we're not
gonna have the vice chairman we always
gonna have somebody else coming from
know from the idea was to keep it strong
and effective working groups are usually
correct me for well they're usually very
small it's very fun I'm not usually
greater than falling five is quite long
about the independent everyone the free
plaintiffs range of nine as long as I
and selling zone okay that person to be
consistent just yes I think so
okay independent from the independence
people would need to be the same person
that attending each time okay okay so
that's what we've suggested we just
we've said he's nice and Miss Weston but
on you kid after Stanley and one
independent yeah but it's going yeah up
down up down up and down the dependent
manner to put it in perfectly to the
advisory non-voting advisory nobody's
get to that for this because our
counselors yeah so okay look seven
- rehung not about the content yes
content discussions it you know it
shouldn't get to focus and things with a
working proficient is but I mean Bellamy
citizen there's just as a as if this is
a technical thing you know yeah yeah
yeah we could retool discussing training
we're not discussing on focus okay so
recommendation then to propose it was
considered observers which Michel and
very kindly done and do we need to put
in that recommendation that we've
already decided on performing the
subcommittee or we're not already done
so we've done yet for me to be in no
yeah I mean I mean I mean we it will be
you know pro-gay progressed but the
review committees asked to hear from
this committee I to opportunity so its
recommendations that there will go as
recommendations through review in inter
Council I mean this committee could say
no we don't want that I mean or they can
all that you you can you could do that
but the intent was that's that's the
request but it doesn't stop that working
group you know the the you know that the
assumption that is going to happen and
officers put in the background be you
know be looking to identify Jan you've
every date with the members have been
mentioned and and the work was required
you know to come into it knowing that
it's all a little bit you know first
time around it's all going to be a
little bit not as you know it will
improve going forward
what we have with that members yeah okay
so the recommendation which it would
work done and reverb committee and
recommends to full capsule when you talk
all firm just saying okay any thank you
all diseases its 2056 thank you for
coming to see me